Would an adaptogen help regulate ADH or vasopressin?
Adaptogen maybe, because adaptogens can affect your pituitary gland.
Um, so it can affect your parathyroid.
I don't know if it would directly affect that.
I don't know.
I don't think so off my head as I think of the physiology.
Last week, I asked about a comment on my ZRT results
about methylation of four hydroxy E2, which
is an esterone derivative.
And you want to be to e-value the report.
Did you see it?
Yes, I e-mailed you back, too.
That in fact, I ordered some ZRT kits.
I like that report because of that.
So it gives you what you're talking about, the Dutch test,
which the ZRT test is a Dutch test, too.
So it's a dried urine test as well, I believe.
And it gives you a couple extra markers
that the Dutch brand test, the Precision Analytics test,
doesn't give you.
And what is the four hydroxy E2?
So that's what I did like that.
So I did e-mail it back and say, I like that test.
So thank you.